you may be following a path that others
have taken and that others will take
after you but nobody sees it the way you
do
what is the creative writing process and
how is it different from other writing
processes well I've done uh
a variety of
jobs worn different hats as Under the
Dome of the writer some of my work was
sort of journalistic
some of it was critical and some of it
is pure creative and they are very very
different hats and even within the
creatives there are different hats so to
speak like if you want to write comedy
you've got to put on a comedy hat you've
got to be you know tuned to look for the
opportunities to be funny or if you're
writing something scary you put on the
scary hat
and you look for those opportunities but
it's it's quite a different thing
to write critically as I did for most of
my career the bulk of my career I was a
kind of a threshold Guardian actually
one of those archetypes whose job is to
say no it's not good enough most of the
time
so we were reading uh individually the
people like me were reading maybe 10
scripts a week
maybe 12 scripts a week and 11 of those
for sure would be
a pass meaning no it's not good enough
it's not ready it's not right for this
studio but every once in a while maybe
one out of 15 or 20 you'd go maybe this
could be turned into something or yes
I'm sticking my neck out for this and
um it's hard to say which of the hats
you're wearing at that point as a reader
of Scripps as a professional analyst of
scripts I had to read as if I were
creating a movie I was an act of the
imagination
and I had to take the roles of the
cinematographer and the director and the
sound guy and the music supervisor and I
had to provide all that and inflate this
thing that's all flattened out on 120
pieces of paper
inflate that into a a full movie as best
as it could be realized you know I tried
to make it the best production of this
even if the script was horrible I tried
to make it the best produced version in
my head so there was a creative act
involved there
um but then you have to get down to uh
uh the the job of explaining why this
works and why that doesn't work and why
this would be good and why that you
shouldn't bother and so forth which is
quite different from the uh the writing
the pure creative writing hat uh I I
like that hat a lot
um
because
you are in God's chair in a way there
even more than as a reader Imagining the
thing you're completely responsible for
this room that I'm imagining the every
chair in it every person in it every
wall hanging every ever you're
responsible for everything and uh and it
has to mean something and that isn't
easy
so uh that's a whole other set of tasks
but I I like using
both sides I think it has something to
do with the sides of the brain that the
analytical side is you know off to one
side and the other is the the more
purely creative they overlap but uh
but I like that the free full creative
thing too
the relationship between creativity and
Imagination
oh interesting what's the relationship
between creativity and Imagination well
I would start with imagination
because uh I think that's when I first
became aware of the possibilities here I
had just been I was maybe five years old
and I had just been read
some fairy tale by my grandmother about
a giant it was probably Jack and the
Beanstalk
and the next day I remember so vividly I
was looking out the back window into our
backyard and there was a big uh hedge
that was the end of the yard and on the
other side was Wilderness in a farm and
you know wild animals and snakes and all
kinds of stuff I didn't ever dare go in
there
um but I'm sitting in this thought of
the giant ran through my mind and I saw
with my imagination a gigantic boot come
down and crash into the yard and I
realized and I jumped back
you know because my imagination had so
thoroughly created that thing
that it was it might as well have been a
giant stepping down into my yard and so
I realized wow imagination is I mean I
actually physically jumped back because
my imagination had done such a good job
of creating that so uh that's uh my sort
of starting point for it and then the
creativity is uh all the things that you
bring to bear
to realize your imagination uh like what
do they say what does it look like how
does it smell taste feel using all the
senses uh those those are things that
come out of uh I think the aftermath of
the imagination that you dream something
up and then you use your creativity to
express it that's how I'm seeing it
today anyway so
and I think you've said as a viewer if
uh at least two of your vital organs
don't respond to a story then it that
it's not really a compelling story yeah
that's a real deep belief of mine that
um this stuff of stories
acts upon the human body more than the
human mind the mind is involved the
imagination is involved of course
but I think this was a belief that
Joseph Campbell had that the images in
the myths Were Somehow programmed to
bypass the brain and the intellectual
function you can still use it but you're
actually being affected below the neck
mostly in the organs of the body and
that's a rule of mind that if two or
more organs of the body are not
secreting fluids or squirting or you
know generating tears or causing the
chemicals in the neck to choke up or
making the heart beat faster all those
are injections of chemicals by these
organs of the body which are somehow
mysteriously programmed to respond if we
see a fireman pick up a baby and carry
it out of the fire
something goes on inside you and makes
you tear up or choke up or makes your
heart swell so I'm a big believer in the
the power of these things and that they
actually operate below the level of the
brain processing it joins in too but
it's more about uh
the direct effect on on the organs of
the body if the path before you is clear
you're probably on someone else's Carl
Young quote how does this relate to the
hero's journey and storytelling wow I I
don't remember hearing this before this
is Carl Jung saying if the path before
you is clear you're probably on somebody
else's path
um yeah I write in the last chapter of
my book The Writer's journey I write
about
an event in my life that I call trust
the path where uh I was lost in the
woods basically and and in in some
danger of getting uh in trouble from you
know being wet and cold and exposure
uh and uh
I
came out of it
with a kind of shamanic experience there
um in the woods that told me this phrase
trust the path
and I really had to think about that a
lot and Jung's quote brings out some
thoughts about it uh you're you're on a
path and I say you should trust that
path
and
um you can get hung up on the fact of
well if there's a path other people have
gone and I'm just following
but I don't think that's the case I
think the real situation is
um
you may be following a path that others
have taken and that others will take
after you but nobody sees it the way you
do you have a unique View and that view
is valuable
so everybody's experience of the journey
is going to be a little different and
you might stop and take a picture in the
same spot others have taken
but your intention and your background
and your wishes for the future all those
things make a difference and
should give you the sense that you know
my view is worthy my view is worth
something and I I say that to people uh
as my kind of parting shot I say uh
please tell your stories because the
world needs them and we need your
particular story your particular
Viewpoint because it's Unique nobody
else sees it the way you do and that
itself has value so I I say to writers
and creators uh that you should uh you
should not be discouraged because things
have been done before others have uh you
know painted before others have sung
songs before uh so what it wasn't yours
and yours is special
so I I kind of leave people with that as
my Parting Shot is trust the path
and especially your path because it's
Unique